[Música]
hace dos años aproximadamente se realizó
un estudio en nueva york'
este estudio permitió determinar que
realmente cuando aprendemos un idioma no
se almacena necesariamente en la corteza
izquierda esto varía según nuestra edad
esto quiere decir que por ejemplo cuando
un niño aprende un segundo idioma este
se almacena a la par del idioma natal
mientras que cuando un adulto aprende un
segundo idioma el lugar donde este
idioma se va a almacenar va a depender
demasiado de la edad que tenga
esto permite que cualquiera pueda
aprender un idioma en cualquier momento
la pandemia es algo que a todos nuestro
modo de imprevisto algo que nadie
esperaba
creo que en ningún momento nos
imaginamos que una enfermedad pudiera
paralizar el mundo de un momento a otro
recuerdo muy bien que se empresas
funcionaban a la perfección en ese
momento todo marchaba bien de la noche a
la mañana una pandemia una de mis
empresas quebró mis ingresos bajaron y
comencé a ver como muchas personas serán
despedidas mutan muchas personas se
quedaban sin trabajo perdían su hogar
las deudas les llegaban hasta la cabeza
realmente era un momento muy difícil
para todos creo que para algunos son una
oportunidad también la pandemia
realmente de enseñanza si nos sigue
dejando demasiadas enseñanzas
como tal
parte de todo esto que la pandemia nos
dejó fue el desempleo me comencé a dar
cuenta que muchas personas estaban
desempleadas tenía amigos que se habían
quedado sin trabajo después de trabajar
muchos años en empresas por ejemplo y
que hasta un amigo que tenía más de 20
años trabaja en un lugar y tuvieron que
hacer recortes
y él quedó despedido y el caso más
cercano que tenía era eliminada
y mamá la despidieron gracias a la
pandemia
mi mamá siempre ha tenido problemas con
el aprendizaje es decir tenía en mente
que es muy difícil aprender algo nuevo y
se centraba y se encerraba en eso
yo me comencé a preocupar
bastante mi mamá no encontraba una
solución al tema del desempleo por su
edad cuando ya había llegado a los 40
años era muy difícil poder obtener un
empleo aplicada aplicaba pero realmente
la crisis era muy fuerte
había que pensar una idea vaga cruzada
por mi cabeza
qué pasa con todas las personas que
están desempleadas y no pueden hacer
nada por ello es decir las oportunidades
no eran lo suficientemente oportunas
para todos entonces qué hacer con todas
estas personas algunas personas
privilegiadas por supuesto que tenían la
oportunidad por ejemplo de optar a hacer
tus trabajos bilingües y me comencé a
dar cuenta de ello
pero quién puede apoyar entonces a todas
aquellas personas desamparadas
de aquí un día pensando en mi habitación
nace la idea por qué no crear una
academia inglés y permitir que las
personas que no consiguen trabajo
estudiarán inglés con un método rápido y
podrán trabajar por ejemplo en un call
center qué es lo que sucede pasando un
sueldo mínimo a un sueldo mayor gracias
a que al aprender un nuevo idioma
se creó crea una carne inglés en plena
pandemia marzo también iniciando a los
18 días de marzo se creó la colonia que
cree tres inscritos el primer mes no es
un negocio sostenible en mantener una
academia con tres escritos par
catedráticos publicidad plataformas
virtuales
en este primer mes hice un trato con mi
dama era uno de los tres inscritos y el
trato fue mira madre yo sé que a ti no
te gusta aprender el inglés y acerálava
secretaria bilingüe entonces suponíamos
que habla inglés hagamos un trato tú
estudias inglés con la única condición
de que te vas a comprometer a conectarte
todos los días ships
y vas a hacer todas las tareas y vas a
practicar todos los días
bueno hicimos un trato lo recuerdo muy
bien nos dimos la mano en la tarde una
tarde de marzo
y se empezó a conectar a recibir clases
de inglés
como me llama había hecho el trato
efectivamente en su primer mes después
de que me llama ni siquiera entendía
hello
haim shani que era
entonces después de ese primer mes mi
mamá ya hablaba pasado presente y
futuro' simple era impresionante
quintáns un mes una persona que tenía en
su cabeza que era imposible aprender
otro yo estaba haciendo
ahora bien qué pasa en el segundo mes de
operación de la academia
perdimos dos alumnos y se quedó solo
mismo nuevamente eso ya que no es
sostenible es decir un emprendimiento
que estaba fallando en la parte
administrativa
qué hacer con ese problema
en un dilema moral realmente estaba
entre cerrar la academia porque no era
rentable pagarle un profesor pagar una
plataforma para que me llame a estudiar
pero el corazón manda así que la
academia sigue operando
pero qué hacer porque se fueron esos dos
alumnos que sucedió que esos dos alumnos
que sí estaban pagando su mensualidad se
fueron
aquí comienza la etapa de
descubrimientos realmente me di cuenta
que lo que hacía falta en estas personas
era disciplina
qué sucede con la disciplina
las personas como pagan un monto mínimo
pagaban 250 quetzales al mes era el
precio inicial no estaban comprometidas
al 100% con su aprendizaje es decir
sentían que era una cantidad mínima para
algunos entonces a veces se conectaban a
veces no eso que propiciaba que el
aprendizaje no se lograra realmente
no practicaban no hacían los ejercicios
y se tenía pensado que en la academia
las personas hicieran ejercicios o
tareas de 10 minutos es decir diez
minutos era la tarea del día diez
minutos al día tú te dedicabas a
estudiar inglés y luego tu clase dos
horas al día
las personas no tenían eso no tenían
disciplina entonces faltaban en sus
clases habían días en los que sólo
estaba a media mañana bien días en los
que sí estaban nuestras personas
y entonces comenzamos a cambiar el
método de la academia y nos dimos cuenta
que realmente el sol enseñar un idioma
el solo educar de esa manera no era
suficiente
porque las personas iban a llegar
siempre con la misma mentalidad
la mentalidad es solo llegar a aprender
el idioma
pero en este segmento tan especial que
estábamos atacando realmente lo que
necesitábamos era ayudarlos a cambiar su
vida como a través de educación de
calidad y a bajo costo un día abre mi
laptop abre mi hoja de cálculo y me puse
a hacer números bueno este tiene que ser
un proyecto autosostenible es un
emprendimiento social entonces hay que
convertirlo en un proyecto sostenible es
decir tiene que ser rentable tiene que
poderse mantener a sí mismo y pagar
todos sus puestos cuál debe de ser el
precio adecuado para que esto funcione
sí cobrando 250 quetzales no lo grabamos
inscritos y aún así pagando publicidad
yo soy mercado lo vivo marketing digital
ni siquiera si lográbamos inscritos
entonces era el dilema más grande
cobramos barato
éramos 250
entonces qué hacer
y acá es donde viene la idea cogeremos
12 dólares al mes
traducido en estudio más 100 quetzales
lanzamos esa publicidad y en el tercer
mes de operación teníamos 20 inscritos
algo funcionado pero hicimos bien y algo
funciona 20 inscritos de esos 20
inscritos en el cuarto mes perdimos a 10
algo fallaba nuevamente qué es lo que
estaba fallando en toda la operación
cuarto mes y no lográbamos ser rentables
en un proyecto pequeño yo me empezaba a
preocupar me llama a seguir estudiando
por cierto para que tenga el dato y
seguir aprendiendo inglés ya ya ya iba
encaminada entonces lo que hacía falta
realmente era la parte de motivación
y la parte de actitud como tal la
motivación y la actitud son importantes
en todo el proceso porque
cuando las personas se conectaban a su
clase realmente lo que hacían era
quedarse sentados apagan su cama reciben
hacer sus cosas en casa porque estaban
recibiendo clases en línea aún no
teníamos la cultura para poder recibir
clases en algunos no estaban preparados
para eso
la actitud
fue fundamental en la academia porque
entonces comenzamos con la actitud
positiva de nuestro staff
nuestro staff nuestros profesores en su
equipo de servicio al cliente y se
preparaba de manera que todos tuviéramos
una cosa en la mente y es cambiar la
vida de las personas a través de la
educación como un idioma como el inglés
puede cambiar la vida de una persona lo
puede hacer si permite que la persona
salte un punto a en dónde está ganando
un salario mínimo y no alcanza para
poder vivir a un punto de donde tiene
más oportunidades de crecer
y las oportunidades se multiplican
aunque ustedes no lo crean las
oportunidades son mucho más grandes al
momento de saber un idioma como en
inglés y permitimos entonces que
segmentos que no habían tenido acceso a
una academia de inglés en su vida
pudieran estudiar por primera vez un
segundo idioma fue algo maravilloso al
ver como las personas a veces no tenían
ni siquiera wifi en su casa pero que
hacían metían una recarga de 5 quetzales
y buscaban la manera de conectarse
habían personas y recuerdo muy bien el
caso de muchos alumnos que tenían que
subirse a los árboles para tener señal y
entonces comenzamos a impactar en toda
guatemala comenzamos a tener alumnos en
toda guatemala porque todo nuestro
estado se trabajó una idea en la cabeza
cambiar vidas de las personas
nuestra meta ya no la sólo enseñar el
inglés eso cualquiera lo puede hacer
enseñó un idioma apoyar a alguien pero
cambiar la vida a las personas y la
mentalidad que ellos están teniendo eso
es distinto ese es un gran reto ya es
ahí donde nosotros entramos entonces
nuestro staff se contagió es idea y dijo
no
la actitud es importante que hacíamos
nosotros como tal como seres humanos no
podemos decir que nos pasa y que no nos
pasa
pero si podemos decidir cómo reaccionar
a ello cómo reaccionar a cada una de las
situaciones que está en constructor es
decir por ejemplo puede que ahorita me
equivoqué y me voy a poner triste y me
quedé parado acá
pero puedo reaccionar de mejor manera y
continuar con mi charla simplemente eso
lo podemos hacer en todo momento y es
cuestión de actitud eso hicimos con
nuestros profesores y nuestros alumnos
entonces nuestros alumnos cuando se
equivocaban como nunca habían tenido la
experiencia en una academia normalmente
estaban chiviado basada en la cabeza y
se sentían mal se sentían mal porque es
equivocado que hicimos con nuestro
estado
les enseñamos que los errores son parte
del proceso para el éxito y entonces las
personas empezaron a quitarse ese
cascarón que no les permitía aprender
ese idioma ya muchas personas que nos
decían es que yo no aprendo ningún
idioma yo no yo soy tosco para el idioma
pero qué pasaba las personas comenzaban
a aprender el idioma y cuando las
personas comenzaban a aprender el idioma
aquí viene la otra parte de motivación
que pasaba con la motivación
cuando se tienen éxitos pequeños las
personas se sienten bien
psicológicamente hablando con éxitos
pequeños nos vamos acercando se activan
ciertos neurotransmisores que permiten
sentirnos bien entonces spears positivos
no se hacen sentir felices entonces qué
es lo que sucede las personas comenzaban
a sentir avances y el método que
desarrollamos en la academia estaba
enfocado para que todos los días y todos
los meses las personas se dieran cuenta
de su propio éxito porque por ejemplo en
cuestiones de disciplina las personas
tenían que asistir un 95% de veces a las
clases eso permitía que se comprometiera
hay el compromiso en cuestiones de
motivación nuestro staff se encargaba de
ello tenías una buena pronunciación se
te hacía ver y a cada uno se trataba de
destacar lo mejor que tenía entonces las
personas se sentían bien estando con
nosotros incluso aumentó el y con una
profesora se accidentó
nadie nadie nadie los alumnos se
conocían
pero los alumnos incluso llamaron a la
profesora y se creó una gran
preocupación interna por la profesora
que se accidentó qué es lo que pasó se
construyó una familia se construyó
confianza entre los alumnos y en tan
solo seis meses ya teníamos a más de 500
alumnos estudiando con nosotros no solo
en guatemala y nicaragua el salvador y
méxico
y fue viral no se pagó por publicidad en
otros países al contrario se hacían
inversiones mínimas en publicidad
conforme el tiempo avanzó se fue
mejorando tuvimos plataforma propia y se
está invirtiendo más en todo el entorno
educativo lo más interesante de todo el
tema es justamente que 12 dólares eran
los necesarios para cambiar una vida es
decir las personas pagaban 100 quetzales
al mes para aprender un idioma
a muchas personas y les costaba pagar
sus 12 dólares y les será muy difícil
hay en personas que nos decían miren
necesito que me en tiempo o 15 días para
poder pagar y se les daba el tiempo
porque la idea del emprendimiento por
ser un emprendimiento social era cambiar
vidas
y se convirtió en un proyecto
autosostenible
cuál fue la carta debajo de la manga
nuestro propio staff todo el staff se
contagió con la misma visión de la
academia
pero sobre todo los profesores no eran
pedagogos vinilo interesante los niños
aprenden a través de la pac de la
pedagogía los adultos a través de la
andragogía que es lo que sucede acá
las personas que daban clases no eran de
andhra goes ni pedagogos eran
agentes de concentrar porque se los
cuento fácil
estas personas que dan clases tenían un
perfil en común y es que cada uno de
ellos había aprendido inglés a su propia
manera no significa que no fueran
profesionales para nada al contrario
significa que a cada uno de estos
profesores les costó aprender inglés
porque no tuvieron la oportunidad y
nadie les brindó la mano en su momento
ahora que ellos estaban en esa posición
de que ya sabían el idioma lo manejaban
y tenían experiencia de más de dos años
en un call center
es lo que quería era aportar a ellos les
hubiera encantado que allí dieran la
mano y los ayudarán a aprender el idioma
qué fue lo que hicimos agarramos este
perfil de profesores y los sumamos a
nuestra visión
entonces juntos fuimos trabajando para
construir la academia
ahora ya tendremos a más de 1000 alumnos
en toda centroamérica creciendo día a
día de salud que crecemos mensualmente
aproximadamente 200 alumnos es un
crecimiento bárbaro
esto quiere decir que con tan solo 12
dólares al mes es posible cambiar vidas
[Aplausos]
[Música]
i